Back in October when I released my 94 Things
You Missed in IT, I theorized that Henry Bowers
may have killed his friends, Victor and Belch,
on the way from his house to the final showdown
at 29 Neibolt.
My reasoning behind the theory was that Henry
watches the tv show seen around Derry where
Pennywise encourages him to “Kill Them All”,
then kills his father.
When we next see him at the 29 Neibolt house,
he pulls up in Belch’s car with more blood
on him than before.
So I thought maybe there was a deleted scene
involving Henry killing his friends and stealing
the car.
I declared that we’d have to wait for the
Blu-Ray to come out to see if I was right.
So fast forward to today.
At the time of me making this video, the Blu-Ray
still isn’t out in my country, but it has
been released in Australia and one of my fans
was nice enough to give me a heads up.
The clip has only surfaced on Instagram so
far, so please excuse the quality, but let’s
roll it.
So it looks like I was spot on with the theory.
But what implications does this have for the
upcoming sequel?
In the book, Belch and Victor die not long
after, at the hands of IT.
In the adult portion, Pennywise exhibits the
forms of both Victor and Belch to help break
Henry out of prison.
Henry apologizes for leaving them to die in
the sewers all those years ago.
As of right now, we don’t even know if Henry
survives the fall into that well in the Neibolt
basement, but if he does live, it’s safe
to say that Victor and Belch probably won’t
be the forms used by IT to break him out of
prison.
That would be one awkward car ride.
If Henry doesn’t live, then with all four
bullies out of the picture now, who is going
to be the new scapegoat for the killings that
took place that summer?
Let me know your ideas in the comments, and
also let me know if you think this deleted
scene should have been removed or not.
And I know what you’re thinking -- CZ how
can I get myself some of that stylish Float.
Merchandise.
For that, you’ll want to head over to the
new CZsWorld Merch Store.
I’ll leave a link in the description.
But most importantly remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.